Film Courage: Alan, your bio says you taught
screenwriting in maximum-security
prisons? Alan Watt, author, screenwriter and founder of the LA writer's lab: Yes. Film Courage: So many questions about
that what did they ask you
first question what did these these
people I'm sure they were happy to see
you very inquisitive it was what did
they ask me they I don't think they
first of all teaching a maximum-security
prison is is it's scary because these
are you know at least initially it's
scary because they you think you're
gonna be surrounded by guards and there
aren't any guards so they send you in
and they close the door and then there's
these hundred guys and me and no guards
and I was initially terrified and but
these guys were so sweet I mean they're
not sending you they're sending people
who have earned the right to be in the
workshop and so they've they've you know
displayed good behavior but it was
initially terrifying and and I got up
there and I'm you know I'm teaching
about transformation and I'm talking
about how one you know the story
ultimately is about how one changes
oneself and or the protagonist
experiences some kind of shift in
perception and they were incredibly
sweet incredibly eager and grateful and
I can't remember any specific question
but I do remember that they had great
questions and that there was there was
this sort of shocking level of humility
with them that I don't get as much with
a lot of my regular students sometimes
you get people and they sort of like
they know it all and they but these guys
had really incredible stories to tell
and there was a there was an openness to
tell these stories all
as if they it almost felt like they were
kind of bursting to tell these stories
and I remember we took a break I was
teaching in out in the high desert at I
can't remember the name of the prison
but they kind of rushed up to me or some
of them did at the break and it was
almost like it was almost like I know
we've only got a little bit of time here
but there's so much I want to learn and
I've got so many questions and and and
wanting to tell me their personal
stories and very very touching it was
very it was it was a very moving
experience it's to teach in a
maximum-security prison I find that so
fascinating that you say that there was
this humility and that they kind of had
this openness whereas if you were maybe
teaching somewhere where I hate to just
assume but if you think that maybe
people hadn't had certain knocks in life
mm-hmm whether they're their own fault
or whether they're not whether they're
innocent or guilty that they would be
it's just interesting I don't know if
it's a class thing I don't know if it's
just life experience I don't know what
it what it is but I find that
fascinating well that's actually what I
came away with was was the this
realization that you know you're her
that's saying there but for the grace of
God go I that these people they do often
come from poverty difficult
circumstances addiction a lot of things
that are kind of beyond their control
and and this is there a lot in life
there is also a lot of you know I mean i
think i think the judicial system is is
racist and biased and and i don't think
it's justice for all and it's kind of
heartbreaking and you see these people
who you know may in in in some instances
may have gotten a raw deal even if
they're guilty you know in the sense
that they know not just that they may
not have gotten proper legal
you're decent legal representation but
that you know you see that there's a lot
of people in life who were kind of
screwed because of just the raw deal
they got growing up so I just came away
with kind of like it's it's we got a lot
to be a lot to be grateful for you know
so when you go back into let's say if
you want to call the mainstream
population I don't know what the for
lack of a better word and you see people
that come to classes or whatever and
they and they challenge different
beliefs about story structure or writing
or the need to take classes or whatever
do you see that they are justified in
being angry about certain things because
sometimes you you look at how angry
people get over something is innocent a
screenwriting and you say what's the
justification for that you can take it
or leave it like if you you know take
what you like leave the rest kind of
thing yeah and and some people seem very
dogmatic about certain things and it
becomes it's almost like a fight about
religion when it's just screenwriting
right well I don't you know I those kind
of those people don't stay very long in
a class and I also I have no desire to
argue with people or write and that's
not true
my interest as a writing teacher is to
get to the truth so if somebody's
arguing with me about something or
astonished Lee's holding a position my
question is is that true is what you're
saying true let's explore that
let's examine it because I have no dog
in this race I don't I'm not dogmatic at
all I have
yeah I've been teaching a long time and
writing a long time and I've got a you
know i I've I've got a method that I'm
that I'm teaching people but I don't
even know if I would actually call it a
method process that I'm teaching and
but yeah I don't really I don't get into
fights with people about writing it's
like you really believe that and you
you're so you're so staunchly holding
that that point of view well then then
good how's it working for you you know
is it is it is it helping you with your
writing if it is then great and if not
then you know I I see it a lot with
writing teachers I think there are a lot
of writing teachers who are it's almost
like they've got to secure their their
sort of place in the world by issuing
everything that isn't what they teach
and that can be I've seen it a lot where
the latest thing is that that some
writing teachers say the three-act
structure is dead it's it's it's
remedial it's it it's it's not going to
it's it's going to kill any creativity
and the problem with that is that they
don't understand what the three-act
structure is because the three-act
structure is has nothing to do with
plotting in my opinion and unfortunately
the a lot of story structure is taught
by story analysts who are sort of
brilliant left brain left brain errs and
are really adept at deconstructing a
masterpiece and and sort of the
implication is that now that we've
deconstructed this you should go off and
write your masterpiece and while there's
tremendous amount of value in in in
studying film theory or you know film
theory because it's that that's that's
you know deconstructing Casablanca or
Citizen Kane is is going to help you
understand how a story was built some
degree but it's not going to teach you
it's not gonna teach you how to organize
your ideas when you look at a movie like
Casablanca and you think about the
Epstein brothers writing you know we're
structuring this this movie they I'm
interested in in the process I'm
interested in how did somebody come to
write this in other words you can you
can sort of like just because you
deconstruct some of you so it's like
vivisection you can't you can't take
something dead and look at all of its
existing parts and then and then
reanimate it it's not going to come back
to life and so just because you can
break down this thing into its it's sort
of separate parts doesn't mean you're
going to uncover the mystery of what the
thing actually is in other words story
structure is really the DNA of your
protagonists transformation that makes
sense the story stories the DNA of a
protagonist transformation it's not you
know in the midpoint there should be a
reversal like I don't even know what
that means you hear all the time with
with these story analysts that should be
reversible what the hell does you know
does does it's a wonderful life have a
reversal that's where mr. Potter offers
Jimmy Stewart a job and Jimmy Stewart
says no I don't know I I don't I think
of I think of story structure as not a
conceptual model something we can figure
out but it's it's more of a experiential
model in other words your protagonist
goes through a series of experiences
that lead to a transformation and I
think if story structure as an immutable
paradigm for a spiritual transformation
it's immutable it never changes but that
doesn't make it that doesn't that
doesn't limit your creativity that
actually paradoxically opens your
creativity in other words when when you
really understand what story structure
is it moves you beyond your limited
imagined
of what your story is I always tell my
writers your idea of your story is not
the whole story it's not that it's
incorrect it's that it's incomplete and
so if you were to distill story
structure to three words it would be
desire surrender transformation so show
me any story there's you're gonna have a
character that wants something desire
you're gonna have a character that lets
go of the meaning they made out of their
goal surrender you're gonna have a
character that experiences
transformation in other words a shift in
perception a reframing of their
relationship to their goal show me a
story that doesn't have that and I'll
show you a story that doesn't work you
know or is really experimental okay but
that's where that's where when people
you know I I have I it happens not when
I teach so much as as if I do a lecture
it to a bunch of people there's always
the the the sort of the contrary and the
person who's like you know I don't agree
with that and I'm like that's great
let's let's talk about that but it's it
it's it's it's usually about something
that they're trying to work out with
themselves and it's not really it's it's
it's it's usually that they I don't know
it's usually like they want they're
looking for some kind of fight rather
than they're actually sincerely
interested in in deepening their process
so do you think that teaching
screenwriting or these books or whatever
is is selling false hope that's one one
criticism of some of what we've seen it
and I don't see why that would be
selling false hope if that's something
someone enjoys and they love the process
of creating okay I love this because I
believe that my job as a writing teacher
is to facilitate writers in finding the
story that lives within them and stay
out of the result in other words when
you get into the result that's when you
get tripped up that's when you don't
really right from your heart that's when
you don't write something that's
actually gonna be meaningful to other
people
and so that's it I always think of
writing as a two-tiered process the
first tier is you have to write it for
yourself and then the second tier is
once you've written it for yourself once
you've written that stuff that you think
oh my god I can't show this to anybody
it's way too personal even if it's
fiction especially if it's fiction it's
there's there's gonna be you've gotta
have some skin in the game you got to be
invested in this thing that you're
writing you've got to let go of this
idea that is it going to sell we can't
you know I remember when I wrote my
first novel I I woke up one day and I
was like I've been writing for a long
time I was making a living as a stand-up
comic but I've been writing for a long
time and I hadn't sold anything and I
thought well you know let me do the math
here clearly I must be a mediocre writer
if I've been writing for this long and I
haven't sold anything so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to stop writing for the
marketplace whatever that is and I'm
gonna write something for myself I'm
gonna write something that really means
something to me and I wrote a story that
and I were really quick there wrote a
novel called Diamond Dogs and got it
through through through this this lawyer
friend of mine got it to an agent she
auctioned it a week later for a
ridiculous amount of money and then it
became a best-seller and it it won a
bunch of awards and and it was it was
the first time I realized that I don't
know anything and when I try and you
know so I saved my idea my story's never
the whole story my idea of of who's
gonna like this or who's gonna like that
is I I don't can't control the result we
none of us have any control over the
result but what we do have control over
is understanding that we're all unique
we all have something valuable to say
and I really believe that as a writer
and as a writing teacher and so I want
to
help writers I can't predict who's some
of my students have gone on to become
best-selling authors showrunners a were
a list screenwriters I didn't know who
they were gonna be but the the
ingredient that I think is is most
valuable isn't talent whatever that is
it's a willingness to learn
it's a humility it's a willingness to be
curious about the story that lives
within you you know it's it's it's the
humility to put it on the page while
staying out of the result that's really
hard for people that's that's the really
challenging that's the really
challenging test that's being a writer
as a marathon it's not a sprint and if
you expect immediate results you know
you you might not stay in the game long
enough to experience the fruits of your
labor you were doing comedy stand-up
comedy you were able to make a living at
it
why transition to writing what was it
because so many people come to LA for
that comic stream that's I I miss
stand-up comedy so much
boy that's a that's a really that's
that's a loaded question to unpack
because there's a lot of reasons but the
the really simple reason is because I
didn't love going on the road and I got
you know and when when I sold my first
novel and they backed up the money truck
I didn't have to go on the road and it
just became this thing where I just I
just started I just sort of became a
full-time writer and would still do
stand-up occasionally you know if
somebody asked me like a coffee shop on
a Friday or Saturday night or something
I'd go into stand-up and loved it but it
just became this thing that it's it's
it's sort of its it sort of gradually
fell away you know and then and then
it's also if you don't do stand-up
comedy every single night
you suck it's it's it's like one of
those things where it's
muscle memory and and you lose it so
quickly and and and so if you're not
doing it and then you do it every you
know three weeks or six weeks you go up
you go oh my god this is so this feels
so weird and and and and you got to get
back into the rhythm so it just it just
became this thing where I'm like I'm
gonna be feeling like going up and
sucking tonight and and so it just
became this thing that fell away from me
I also you know stand-up comedy at it
attracts a lot of people who are kind of
damaged and broken and you know and I'm
not I'm not excluding myself from that
but it was it's a world where you've got
to be really committed to doing that
and I you know I went through a lotta I
went through a lot of stuff I had a lot
of a lot of my friends I mean I I've had
I think seven friends commit suicide
stand-up comic just attracts a you know
dark element and I there was a part of
me my nickname in my 20s with all my
comic friends was crazy a lot okay so
these people are all out of their minds
and I I was the cream is the crazy one
and I think it was because at that time
I was really depressed and you know just
really really not in a good place but I
talked about it all the time I was like
I I I'm like I'm really really not doing
good today and I think it made them
uncomfortable some of them and so I got
the nickname crazy I want and you know
in retrospect I think that it was that
part of me that kind of I I think I had
a survival instinct that was like I I
would rather be comfortable in my own
skin
van chase after some you know illusory
fame or whatever
and so I you know I anyway I did I
I was kind of that part of me was kind
of okay letting go a stand-up and
meeting a great woman getting married
having a kid becoming a writing teacher
as a witch is turned out to be probably
something that I'm m'as born to do and
and and and you know I I love being a
writer and I and I and I love I just
just published a new novel last week
that came out and but yeah yes stand up
is you've got to really want it badly
when you see people who are successful
stand-ups you're seeing people who have
sacrificed probably a tremendous amount
to be doing what they're doing and I
have a lot of respect for for for
stand-up comics and and and compassion
they're there they're my people I love
them and I I really feel a kinship with
comics now I feel like there's there's a
brotherhood and sisterhood with comics
that nobody else understands with
stand-up comics nobody I don't think
anybody understands that because you
know when I talk to people who aren't
stand-up comics they you just even the
language when they talk about them
there's there's an exotic quality to
stand-up comics when people talk about
them they're there they're there people
are fascinated with stand-up comics I
wish I had an ending to this the
sentence which came first the comedy or
the writing comedy comedy well I mean
the economy you you write your own
material but I was I was in I was in
high school and I went to the School of
the Arts in Toronto when I was about 17
or 18 and they had amateur nights on
Monday nights at Yuk Yuk's in Toronto
and I I just started going there on
Monday nights and I was terrible just
bombing you know every Monday night but
I wanted it so badly and
I remember I remember there was a guy
who would he would throw up before he
went on stage every time and I don't
think that was that uncommon it's it's
it's it's like it's bizarre this thing
is so terrifying to do and yet it's a
compulsion and and I you know if you
really work hard at it you start to
understand the mechanics of a joke and
it becomes really addictive like there's
no greater high then going onstage for
45 minutes or an hour in front of 400
people on a Saturday night and just
killing where they're just eating out
eating out of your hand
you know it's it's it and just getting
one laugh after another it's just it's
the greatest feeling in the world
it's I get you know I get why people
don't ever want to stop doing that you
know but the beginning stages is really
that I use stage yeah I mean for me I
can remember going to clubs with this
person while they would do their acts
and maybe there'd be five people in the
audience and then I saw her at the pain
that this person went through outside of
there and and that was their outlet for
it and then I got why they were addicted
to it you know oh yeah it's great it's
the great when you when you when you
start to get an act and you start to
yeah you start to get laughs you start
to get your stage legs it's it's really
great I mean I get why people you hear
Jerry Seinfeld in jail and I'll say we
don't go on vacation vacation for us is
going on the road I get it I mean
wouldn't want to you know go out in
front of 5000 people and just kill and
it's it's the best but then at some
point you were writing or learning about
novel structure or from the beginning
from the beginning I always yeah I
always wanted to write stories okay yeah
and so at some point you must have had
enough time to work on this novel that
you eventually got to your lawyer friend
who got to the publisher well I mean I
never had a real job I was I mean I I I
went on the road I actually dropped out
of high school three months prior to
graduate
because I got this one Road gig I mean I
was still on amateur nights but the the
booking agent liked me and and I had
about I had I probably had about 12
minutes of material and I was I was
supposed to do 25 minutes at this club
in London Ontario and so I I wrote the
Rhett I wrote my material on the bus on
the way to this gig and I dropped out of
high school so I could do this weekend
gig and and then that was it from there
I just started started getting some work
and and making a really meager living
but enough to just barely pay the rent
and and then and then from there it just
sort of evolved this was in the 80s when
there were there were so many comedy
clubs opening and there was such a
dearth of actual really funny people
like there's a there's a there's a quote
from I think it's Seinfeld he says in
the 70s there were 100 comics and ten at
ten of them were funny and in the 80s
there were 10,000 comics and ten of them
were funny okay so funny is a rare
commodity but in the eighties if you
could even fake funny you could make a
living not a great living but you could
make a living and so I started making a
living pretty pretty early on I don't
think I was funny for the first five
years but you can you can fake being
funny - to people - I don't know why I'm
going off on this tangent but but you
know the really great comics are
originals but our in the 80s they were
you know people were just sort of
ripping off other people's personas or
stealing their premises or you know
there were a lot of hack you you know
there's just a lot of hacks a lot of
hack premises
you know airline material or the
difference between you know cats and
dogs or you know men and women and and
just sort of hackneyed premises that are
going to always elicit laughter but but
it you know
just because you're just cuz you're
getting laughs doesn't mean you're funny
so then once the book was picked up you
thought okay well then maybe this
writing thing will become more of a
habit and how did you then train
yourself to show up every day to write
or maybe it wasn't every day to write it
was every day and there was no training
it's just it was just passion
I just always I just loved writing I
just loved it's it's it's harder now
because my schedules gotten so busy with
teaching and family and and you know
making you know I'm setting up my next
movie to make but I just get up early
now and write I get up before my son
gets up and and get to work but I I
don't know I I I can't say that it's not
difficult and that I don't get
distracted but I've never I love writing
and I work hard so I I try and write
every single day I definitely wrote
everyday for you know the first 15 years
you know before I got married and had a
kid you know so 20 years so you grew up
in Canada and you grew up on a farm
yeah grew up in a strawberry farm Wow
and so was that part of your daily
routine to get up early and you're
tending to these berries or well the
berries the berry strawberry season is
about three and a half weeks okay
because doesn't last very long but no
but I was I was a kid then so I was I
mean I wrote then but I wasn't writing
everyday I mean I probably started
writing when I was about 15 or I I
remember the first time I really
realized I I wanted to write was in the
sixth grade I had a teacher named mr.
Bell Smith and he said he had us write a
five chapter novel about being
shipwrecked and it was the first time I
really lost myself and my imagination
and created this whole world on a desert
island this guy in a desert
the friends uh you know a lion and and
and and and I thought this is amazing I
didn't know I could do this and and then
and then and then was shocked that that
was the last time any teacher ever asked
us to be creative and but but it
activated this yearning and me for this
desire to tell stories and so I would
write little plays and you know and
write jokes and stuff like that and I'd
watch you know the The Tonight Show and
and see these comics come out and it
just seemed like the most amazing thing
this dude comes out or this woman and
makes you laugh you're just sitting at
home watching this tube and this guy and
you're laughing for five minutes and
he's you know there's there's no you
know there's it's just magic aha how do
you do that and and and so that was that
was something that I wanted to do but it
was always it was always storytelling
and and and comedy and yeah when did you
come to Los Angeles I came to Los
Angeles in 94 January first remember I
played the the Hyatt Hotel in
Indianapolis for New Year's Eve and and
then and then flew I'd been living in
New York I went back to Canada and then
I Floop here and I was here seventeen
days before the big earthquake hmm which
was I remember yeah and so I've been
here for two weeks and I thought what
the hell are these people doing out here
you've got to be insane to live here
because I just I I didn't realize that
this doesn't happen every two weeks I I
just figured this was a regular thing
and and and so I you know seriously
considered leaving but then again you
know that's the addiction it's like I
want to give up this this dream so you
know so I stayed but a lot of people did
leave after the earthquake yeah so were
you then going to the comedy store these
different places to play
yeah yeah The Improv mostly The Improv
the Laugh Factory Wow yeah yeah that
some managers brought me out here and
and yeah I did a little bit on Seinfeld
and and that was my one acting job at
some point though you then make the
decision that you're gonna do the
writing and the books and the courses
when did you write the 90 day screenplay
book there the 90 day novel came out in
2010 the 90 day screenplay was I don't
know maybe 2012-13 something like that
okay is there a chapter in the 90 day
screenplay book that is most contested
or people have the most questions about
one part of the process I'm not really
aware of anything being particularly
contested I get a lot of people who love
it but it is I think different than a
lot of the screen writing books out
there and I think it's my perception of
it is is that it's it's very much of a
process and and less about result and I
think that when we lose ourselves in the
process the results can take care of
themselves and one of the things that
that I teach here's my cat I don't know
if you're picking that up when there's
Captain but one of the things that is
that I talk about is how dilemma is the
source of the story and a lot of writing
books talk about the dramatic problem
and the implication it for with that for
me and and why I I was resistant to a
lot of the writing books that I read is
that problems are solved their
intellectual you solve a problem
dilemmas are resolved through ishes
through a shift in perception and so
something I I sort of I didn't discover
this but I sort of drilled down into it
is that the source of our story is our
protagonist dilemma
a dilemma is a problem that can't be
solved without creating another problem
you know you've got a story when what
your protagonist wants is impossible to
achieve based on their current approach
or their current identity okay in other
words it's going to necessitate a shift
in perception okay they're going to have
to become a sort of new person so to
speak by the end of the story so you
know like when you think about problems
you think about like I have a flat tire
I called triple-a they solved my problem
okay not an interesting story but if I
have a flat tire and I'm out in the
desert and I call triple-a and this guy
and I'm dying of thirst and this guy
drives out to the desert and it's the
guy who's sleeping with my wife now I've
got an interesting story now I want to
kill the man who's here to save my life
okay so when you can connect to your
protagonists dilemma then you've got
something to work with the dilemma is
the source of your story and if you look
at any great story you've got a clear
dilemma okay and when you can connect to
that then then you've got something to
work with so that's one of the things
that I help writers with is
understanding the dilemma but it's a
more holistic way you know it's it's not
like it's not like let's figure out your
prop your premise the premise is born
out of the protagonists dilemma okay and
so it's I just think it's it's it's for
me it's a more organic way of working
and then you start to see how plot
emerges out of the characters struggle
okay so when I start to and I'm not
talking about in election well
intellectualizing the dilemma be key
because you can't problems are solved
they're gonna let you can't figure out
when you try and figure out your
protagonist dilemma you get stuck but
when you start to connect here to the
experience of the dilemma all sorts of
images and ideas and situations start to
emerge to support that and and and so
that's sometimes people call that the
brainstorming part of the
the process and so the the first part of
the 90-day screenplay is just doing a
lot of free writing imagining your
character or your protagonist in
relationship to other characters and
before you start to put a framework
around it or start to insist on any kind
of structure for it do you think some
people get very confused thinking their
dilemma is their problem and it's not
like when you were talking to the
prisoners were they very clear about
what the problem was in their story
maybe you didn't get into all that with
them I don't know if I got into that
with them I can't remember that but
sometimes writers get confused about the
difference between problem and dilemma
and you know problems are solved so that
like I you know if I said well that's
that that's solvable it's not a it's
it's an aspect of the dilemma you know
like if if in other words here's let's
let's a part of the story could be that
I I get a flat tire and I have to get my
flat tire fixed but the dilemma is is in
other words there's a jumping all over
the place here there's a movement to a
scene and so if a scene begins with a
problem like I got a flat tire and at
the end of this at the end of the scene
I get my flat tire fixed and nothing
else happens we don't have a story what
has to happen is by the end of the scene
I can get my flat tire fixed but
something else happens that's going to
lead the story in any direction in other
words my dilemma wasn't the flat tire
the dilemma is my false belief about
what the flat tire means I don't know if
that makes sense but in other words art
sometimes
here's what writers get stuck writers
think when you hear the term dramatic
problem dramatic problem you assume or
you may assume that it's your job to
figure out your characters solution to
their problem
Einstein says you can't solve a problem
at the same level of consciousness that
created the problem
in other words it's not difficult it's
impossible
you're never gonna figure out your
protagonists transformation but what you
know so so what you don't want to do is
you don't want to think that your
character is is a clean line from the
beginning to the end of the story you
want you need to understand that your
protagonist is going to die at the end
of Act two they're gonna die to their
old identity I don't mean they're
physically gonna die but they're gonna
die too they're they're they're they're
going to be forced to surrender
the meaning they made out of their goal
when Jimmy Stewart leaves Bedford Falls
then he'll have a wonderful life the end
of act 2 is my life is worth I'm worth
more dead than alive ok so he dies to
his old identity he and you know it's
it's it's a great moment where he jumps
off the bridge he wants to jump he wants
to commit suicide he wants to jump into
the icy water now I love this image
because Clarence jumps into the icy
water and so the action is the same this
yeah nobody ever questions this but he
jumps in to save somebody else so he
doesn't he doesn't die he's you know
he's reborn and that's the beginning of
Act three ok so then I'll give you my
version of a marginalized story voice ok
lemma versus a middle class one
marginalized one would be a little girl
wants to go to a birthday party but her
the friends in the neighborhood the
mothers know that her mom cleans houses
right and they don't she's nice but we
don't really know or dear I'm so sorry
and the middle class one is someone's
applying for colleges but it turns out
most of her friends are getting accepted
to another one and she's not sure if her
GPA is good enough to get into that one
ok and so she's like worried that oh my
gosh I'm gonna lose all my my good high
school friends and what's gonna happen
am i standing in that sort of group so
these are like seeds of a story right
two to two
ok so tell me what's your question my
question is are the stakes higher for
the author with the marginalized voice
that means non-inclusion into a group
whereas the other one the middle-class
one is more worried about just maybe
losing sort of footing and maybe losing
touch it Oh stakes higher for one versus
two I think that I I don't think of
stakes I mean gosh I I don't know how to
answer that question because I don't
think the the stakes are about the the
the actual situation the stakes are
really about the ability for the writer
to convey a sense of you know urgency or
anxiety in other words yeah but that one
that's not we're not really talking
about dilemma we're just talking about
stakes the stakes should always be life
and death in every story
they're always life and death if Jan
Brady doesn't get a date with tad
Hamilton she will absolutely die
snakes are always life and death mm-hmm
if they're anything less than life and
death we don't care at all we don't care
at all got it okay you know so so but
but if you want to talk about dilemma
there are two ingredients to a dilemma
as I see so it dilemma is a problem that
can't be solved without creating another
problem and when you connect to your
dilemma you're connecting to the
aliveness in your story there are two
ingredients to a dilemma a powerful want
a powerful desire okay and a false
belief a misperception of myself or the
world okay and so when Sally loves me
then I'll be complete okay now that's
the big that's the beginning of a story
I got to get Sally to love me in order
to be complete do you see a powerful
desire if Sally doesn't love me my life
will be unimaginable and the false
belief is that Sally will complete me at
some point so we've got a powerful
desire remember that story structures
desire surrender transformation we've
got a surrender I mean I'm going to have
to let go of the meaning I make out of
my goal as long as I believe that
Sally's love completely
to me I will forever be in bondage to
Sally or my idea of Sally's love because
the stand and the the audience of the
reader is going to be disappointed if
all that happens at the end of the story
is that Sally loves me that's gonna be a
really does
if Jimmy Stewart left Bedford Falls at
the end of It's a Wonderful Life
we would be disappointed because that's
not what the stories about stories and
about the plot is about will Sally love
me the theme is about completeness what
does it mean to be complete oh it
doesn't mean completeness comes from
outside of ourselves it comes from
within okay so that's that's a dilemma
the dilemma is what is it the theme is
completeness you know if you're doing a
story about justice let's say I'm in
prison and or freedom let's say let's
say this is a story about what does it
mean to be free so if I'm in prison and
I want to I want to be free I might
believe at the beginning of the story
that when I escape then I'll be free
okay and that's that's the dilemma
that's the dramatic question and then
through the story
I might actually succeed in escaping and
discover that I'm still not free that
could be the dark night of the soul
let's say I let's say I escaped with
another buddy and were shackled and we
and we get away and then he trips and
you know twists his ankle and now I've
got to decide you know I really want to
be free but now now I got to take a
blunt instrument and kill my buddy and
you know what I mean and get a okay and
now now am I free you know what I'm
saying and they're chasing after me and
and so in my in my attempt to become
free in your protagonists attempt to get
what he or she wants they move
increasingly away from their desire okay
so my attempt to be free moves me
further away from freedom leading to the
end of act 2 where I have to let go of
the meaning I made out of my goal ie
when I escaped prison then I'll be free
end of act 2 I discover that free true
freedom
comes from within and I might discover
at the end of the story that freedom
might involve going back to prison
taking responsibility for my crime okay
and so that's the shift in perception so
that would be so desire I want to be
free surrender I have to let go of the
meaning of my false belief of what
freedom means and transformation I have
a new understanding of freedom
I think you'd use the social network in
another video I watched oh you want to
use that as an analogy as well because I
found that interesting
oh yeah yeah I think it's a gosh that
was a long time ago so so the dilemma of
the social network is is that is the
tension between integrity and ambition
okay so if I'm really ambitious and I
want to make a billion dollars I I you
know it's the same kind of thing I set
out on this this this quest but did I
steal this idea from these two gorgeous
twins yeah and and and so and I and
that's what that's what the social
network explores every single scene
examines the dilemma of integrity of
integrity versus ambition okay and so
he's driven by his ambition what do I
want I want to succeed what do I need I
need to do the right thing okay and I
think I think it's kind of an ambiguous
ending but it leaves us with that
question you know does the end satisfy
the means or doesn't yeah something like
that do you think most writers know what
their story really is about I think at
some point it's it's always gonna be
kind of a mystery I don't know that we
have to know what it's about but I think
we have to be curious as to what it's
about okay and that's that's the
difference because when I I when I'm
working with writers and and we work
with something I call the story
structure questions and I've got a
series of experiential questions okay so
there and people say oh I I answered
these questions like they're not meant
to be answered then
to be inquired into and so I think James
Brooks said that he didn't know what as
good as it gets was about I think until
he watched it with the first audience
and that's when he realized what it was
about and so um I don't know that we
have to know in some fundamental way
what the things about I also think that
it can change but if we're not curious
about the theme at some point the story
can get away on you the plot can get
away on you you can become so seduced by
your by your plot twists or bite bite
but by the movement of the plot that you
can this the the the the theme can
become untethered and you can lose the
why the story wanted to exist in the
first place I worked with writers
sometimes and and they will write a
really great messy first draft and then
they'll give their draft to their best
friend to read and their best friend
will go I really like chapter four six
and seven but I didn't really like
chapter three nine and ten and so
they'll take out the chapters they
didn't like but the in other words they
will abdicate authority over their work
to somebody else they'll they'll it and
this is what I'm always trying to help
writers understand that that you know
your story better than anybody else even
though you don't know your story because
there's something that you want to
express that's valid okay it's valid and
just because the story isn't doing
everything you want it to do or it's not
totally working doesn't mean that what
you have to express on a fundamental
level isn't valid and so the job is to
stay with the process you know stay with
the process don't get into the result
don't go okay if I get rid of chapter
nine and ten nobody's going to know that
II know there's something you need to
ask yourself what was in Chapter nine
that you are trying to express and let's
start to call that matisse let's start
to call that so that we can
find that through line because
everything we write either belongs or is
leading us to what ultimately belongs in
the story so if I throw something out
without asking without really being
curious why I'm throwing it out I'm
doing myself a disservice and so I'll
see people who will take these they'll
have these wonderful messy first drafts
and then they will start to it'll just
start to get worse and worse because
they're not trusting the reason they
wrote the thing in the first place
or they'll give it to an agent an agent
will say it'll be more commercial if you
do this to it sometimes that can work
but sometimes what that you can kill the
aliveness of of something because you're
you're giving it away
have you been given notes about
something a story is screenplay
and you are like wait a minute this is
going to kill the aliveness to it and
you had to go back and say well how do I
make these changes that they want what
keep that spark to it that's tough
that is tough that is - and that's
that's the writers job is to it is to
take the spirit of the note without
taking the the mechanics sometimes
because because you know sometimes
you're getting notes from an executive
and they'll say you know I don't like
this scene it's not working or you
should take this out and you've got if
you don't if you're not connected to why
you're telling the story if you're not
connected to the magic then you you can
you can lose that magic bye
and and what here's what will happen is
the executive will read the new draft
and they'll go this isn't working and
you go but I just did what you asked me
to do yeah but a good executive will go
that's not what I asked you to do I told
you this wasn't working and now it's
your job to go fix what I want you to
fix but I'm not a you know they're not a
writer so they're expecting you to do
your job and so you know there are a lot
of really good executives
who understand that when they're giving
you a note they're also expecting you to
you know they're expecting some kind of
alchemical process to happen so that you
can distill the note to its nature and
give them back something that's working
you know it was like Charlie Kaufman he
when he wrote adaptation
he was adapting the orchid thief and
they were expecting an adaptation of
that novel Charlie Kaufman is not in
that novel okay and so he he he
distilled the that he took that novel
and then it went through Charlie Kaufman
and he wrote this really wonderful
brilliant mad story and when they got it
from what I understand they said what
the hell is this and then a couple of
days later they went oh this is
wonderful but it took them a while I
think to get on board and realized that
he that that that's what they that's why
they hired him because they were they
were gonna get his voice and his thing
and so if we don't trust our voice you
know it's a challenge for the writers
you've got to trust your voice in the
midst of all of the fears if I don't
want to lose this job I don't always
this gig I don't you know I I don't want
to disappoint you know these people that
you know that's part of it you know
you're probably going to get replaced in
Hollywood if you're a screenwriter
doesn't mean that you did a bad job it
just means they're just they're just
covering their asses you think being a
stand-up helps you come to peace with
that or maybe just because when you're
up there I'm sure it's you're basically
naked almost you're very raw and you've
got hecklers you've got people with all
sorts of agendas throwing stuff at you
metaphorically physically whatever and
you I think at some point you you
probably become more comfortable in that
space maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm just
assuming I know I think therapy did that
but I don't think don't think comedy
gave me a thicker you know I didn't know
I don't know no it
uh-huh III would say yeah therapy okay
yeah yeah and just realizing that that
it's it's the reason I think that
writers or anybody I don't know where
I'm going this it I I think early on I
made I thought as a writer my identity
was tied to my creative work and that's
dangerous that can that can really mess
you up I can make you a perfectionist
that can make you bitter that can make
you a victim and it's not it's got
nothing to do with my self-worth and so
in fact I think of if you're a
storyteller that's that's a great luxury
and it's a privilege and so you get to
tell stories and the stories aren't
coming from if they're if you really
want to tell great personal stories you
want to be connected to the universal
you want to be connected to why this is
going to be relatable to other people
that's not going to make your horse work
less personal it's gonna make it more
personal okay because you're gonna be
more willing to really get into the
nitty-gritty of your struggle because
you're going to understand the
transformation I don't know if that's
does that make sense yeah so when you
decided that I'm still gonna be creative
but I'm gonna almost have like is it
almost like having two lives one is
where you're human and the other one is
where you're a creator who's having a
human experience I know that sounds so
cliche but and then if someone rejects
me for my creator persona that doesn't
mean I'm a bad human well I yeah I guess
so but I mean yeah yeah like it's it's
it always sucks getting rejected but
writers are constantly being rejected
and it's just part of it like it just
the more you do the more it just rolls
off
back in other words like give me an
example let's say let's say I write a
romantic comedy and it gets into the
hands of a guy who makes horror movies
and he goes we're passing on this
they're not passing on it because it
lacks quality or value they're passing
on it because they make horror movies
and that's Hollywood is that is that it
and I'm just using a broad
generalization I'm talking about genre
but but you can write a script that that
may not speak to the person that doesn't
mean that the script doesn't have value
you hear about these scripts that are in
in development for five ten to fifteen
twenty years and they finally get made
and then they win an Oscar it's because
somebody believed in them and they could
they had a vision and they could see
what that thing want it to be it's
difficult sometimes to read a screenplay
and be able to see what the movies gonna
be you know so you've got a you've got
to believe in yourself you've gotta
believe in yourself and and I think it
can be easy if something gets rejected
here's the other thing if something's
getting rejected a lot you also need to
have the humility to go well maybe this
isn't doing everything I need it to be
doing okay and so that's where craft
comes in that's where you really have to
understand what you're trying to do and
and sometimes the you know you can hear
it writers there's there's a there's a
fine line between being stubborn and and
having the humility to be teachable you
know because if you don't have the
humility to be teachable and and here
why something's not working for them you
can kind of get stuck and then going
back to working in the the
maximum-security prison right I didn't
do a lot okay yeah okay so the two times
or whatever however many times sorry you
saw that humility in them
how easy was it to have them as sort of
a captive audience sorry that's wrong
scratch that
I guess what I'm trying to say is so
many people they go to a great school
and they've kind of been groomed all
their life that they're like this golden
child and they're great and they're
gonna come and and and everything they
do is fantastic and that's great they
have this wonderful support system right
and then I think in some sense that can
hurt them
here in this industry because it's a
rude awakening when someone doesn't
agree with their work doesn't mean they
don't like that person so when you saw
people that maybe had either been born
with more humility or had been forced to
adopt that attitude I think this
business will you will either you know
become humble or bitter so because
you're always going to be getting
rejected constantly constantly getting
rejected but it's not yeah it's not
personal I'm not sure if I'm answering
your question oh it's great and I love
it where it where does the road diverge
for the humility oh I agree that totally
agree with you well I think it's just I
think it's just you know I don't know if
you can teach that I don't know if you
can
III think it's just humility is gonna
make you a better writer because you're
going to you're going to it's going to
give you humanity you're gonna have
compassion you're going to you know it's
in other words humility is just it's
gonna make your job easier because
you're gonna also have compassion for
yourself you know it's it's going to
it's gonna widen your perspective you're
going to you're gonna see why your
writing isn't doing everything you want
it to do because as writers I think
we've all got blind spots we don't you
know there William Goldman talks about
how you come up with these ideas and you
can see this movie in your head and then
you start to write it and once you start
to write it these ideas become
earthbound you know they're earthbound
they're not there it's it's really hard
work it's really hard work to create a
great story
and and I just think humility is just
something that if you don't have it you
might want to find a waited you know
you're gonna become humble in a
Hollywood just by virtue of the
rejection but what you I don't think
there's a way to exercise humility but I
think there there there there is a way
to I think if you have compassion for
yourself and for other people and and
are gentle with yourself and and have
some a healthy perception of rejection
or an understanding that I'm not being
rejected it's going it's going to lead
to just a happier life why is it
important that the hero experience false
hope Oh false hope is a very necessary
point in the hero's journey the
protagonist journey because without it
there won't be a context for the
surrender at the end of the second act
okay so let me give you an example let's
say I'm trying to think of a story well
let's let's just let's just say a
character let's say I want Sally to love
me so I'll be complete okay the false
hope is the moment where I have a first
date with Sally and we kiss and yes I'm
gonna get what I want but what I want is
for Sally to love me but the reason I
want it is so that I'll be complete okay
so the false hope is it's sort of like
going to Vegas and putting a nickel in
the slot and a dime comes out and you go
by midnight I'll be a millionaire I just
doubled my money and then the next day
you leave town on a greyhound that's the
the false hope is the misperception the
protagonist has about their situation
okay what the the the the false hope is
where the protagonist is not yet aware
that that what they're struggling with
is not a problem it's a dilemma they
think they've got a problem
they don't they've got a dilemma okay
and so so that's what the false hope is
okay without the false hope no context
for the surrender we don't understand
what they're surrendering because the
protagonist isn't surrender I'm not
surrendering my desire for Sally at the
end of the second act I'm surrendering
I'm letting go of the realization that
as long as I believe that Sally will
complete me I'm I'm screwed okay so
that's I'm surrendering the meaning I
make out of my goal I'm not surrendering
my goal the goal never goes away I never
stopped wanting Sally to love me
by the way this is Billy Crystal's POV
and one Harry Met Sally
no no I was picturing them in the
restaurant scene okay I'm just using
you're just using right Sally outs just
I always I don't know why I was talking
about Sally and me sure it's like a
codependent relationship and you're
you're thinking that this person's going
to complete you and Annie or whatever it
is it could be about if the theme is if
the theme is freedom you know I was
talking about the the prison I have to
let go of the belief that escape will
lead to freedom if it's justice I have
to let go of the false belief that so
the false hope let's say let's say my
stories about justice I want justice
they screwed me over I'm gonna get
revenge the false hope is yes revenge is
within my reach okay that would be that
would be the false hope moment the
surrender would be the realization that
an eye for an eye leaves the whole world
blind okay so the end of Act two there
is no such thing as justice through
revenge you know and then I might
discover the Justice comes through a
wider perspective perhaps compassion you
know understanding my situation in a new
way that makes sense so the false hope
is is where I believe that I believe
that through revenge I will justice will
be meted out
can we talk about backstory for the
character is it crucial not so much with
a screenplay backstory is crucial with
every story I mean I can't think of a
story that doesn't you know need some
kind of backstory so but yeah the the
the one of the first things I do when
I'm working in the 90 day novel or the
90 day screenplay the first month of the
workshop is spent imagining the world of
your story which includes the backstory
okay so I they're they're not a separate
thing in other words I want to lose
myself in the world of the story so that
the because backstory is going to become
exposition right so so so it's necessary
it's sort of like looking at a painting
if you ever see those $49 paintings when
you drive out to like the airport or
something they're selling them on the
sides of the roads and it's a landscape
but it's completely flat because it's
one coat
there's no undercoat okay so the
backstory is the undercoat you can't
really see it but you can feel it you
know so like if you if you're if you're
gonna have a snowy landscape your
undercoat you're gonna be using you know
numbers and and browns and and dark
colors so that we can start to
experience the depth of the snow you
can't explain it white it's it's it's
it's just it just looks it's just gonna
look cheesy so that that's that's the
more work you do in really connecting to
your characters backstories the more
it's that that Bachelor is going to
start to get infused into into the
characters experience it's going to be
it's going to be in the dialogue we're
gonna be it's going to be in the flavor
of their language it's gonna be in the
detail of their you know of their
it's gonna it's gonna be in the detail
in terms of revealing that backstory to
the audience how how much can you hold
that back though I realize maybe then
the writer needs to know that backstory
right away but in terms of revealing it
to the audience let's say in a film how
much of how effective is it to really
hold back that backstory or should be
revealed right away because I was
thinking like I just saw this movie the
Mustang and he's in prison and you don't
totally know why he's there right you're
just seeing his life and he's working
with these horses and Bruce Dern is like
this guy that's kind of pushing him
around he's charge of the horses right
then you finally realize what it was
that landed him there who this woman is
that comes to visit him for these
visitations and tension between them but
it was really great because you didn't
know it that's a great question because
because the so you're talking about
mystery and and a lot of the times
writers confuse mystery with withholding
essential information to move the story
forward in other words don't like if
you're if you're writing a mystery you
don't want to confuse your reader or
your audience or you don't want to
withhold something that we actually need
to know what makes a mystery really fun
is that you gave us all of the essential
information but in a way where we
weren't able to put it together and we
experienced the delicious surprise of oh
my god that makes perfect sense and and
and there's some kind of transformative
experience but if you're writing a
mystery
and-and-and-and you're withholding
something essential for us to understand
what needs what happens next we're just
gonna be confused you know or we're
gonna be annoyed no it was done in a way
that no no I'm not so Mustang or saying
I'm saying they probably did it yeah
they did if you didn't do so so I'm
saying that there is there is the goal
with backstory is to find ways to
dramatize or disguise exposition
okay you want to dramatize it you want
or the sky I mean if your dramatizing it
you are disguising it but like I used to
do an exercise with my student having
done a long time but we go around the
table and I'd say okay Jack and Jill
went up the hill to fetch a pail of
water now
who what's Jack and Jill's relationship
and the first person say they're brother
and sister okay
second person how old are they they go
they're 25 and why are they going up the
hill to fetch a pail of water why do
they need to water the house is on fire
okay and then I go okay now that's all
that's all exposition now I want you to
write a dramatic scene that includes all
of that information but you can't say
Jack and Jill are 25 years old you've
got to find a way to convey that
information that backstory or that that
exposition without us knowing that or
the backstory would probably be why
they're going up the hill to fetch a
pail of water so we need to has they're
on their way up the hill we need to you
want to find a way for us to experience
that their house is on fire
does that make sense it does right so so
you're you're showing not telling you
want to show and not tell exactly yeah
yeah we want to experience it we want it
you know filmmaking is is taking the
audience through a series of experiences
that lead to a transformation
locked in here Oh a reluctant hero a
reluctant are you talking about the end
of Act one where I always talk about how
our protagonist makes a decision at the
end of the first act and that there's
reluctance around this decision and the
reluctance is a function of the dilemma
in other words if if your if your
protagonist doesn't experience
reluctance we're not going to understand
what the decision means
okay so I'll give me an example let's
say Romeo and Julia the the the the
inciting incident is Romeo sees Juliet
okay so oh my god I'm in love and then
the opposing argument which is something
I talk about in the workshops is where
we understand the dilemma oh my god I'm
in love with the enemy of my father okay
I'm in love with the family the family
member that's the enemy of my family and
then the decision is to in spite of that
go and stand under Juliet's balcony and
profess his love so he's not reluctant
to profess his love he's reluctant to
get killed by her father okay so they
were elect so if that if that's what
you're asking me they're reluctant here
because that's I think in terms of how
can I find my protagonists reluctance at
the end of Act two the reluctance isn't
about getting what I want the reluctance
is about what it will mean if I try to
get what I want
okay so so so Romeo wants love he
doesn't want to get killed that's what
keeps that's his dilemma I I want true
love but true love will mean could mean
the death of me okay if you can find
your protagonists reluctance at the end
of the first act okay with with regards
to this decision you're going to be
connected to your the tension your
protagonists dilemma your story is gonna
build in meaning as it progresses okay
because that's our goal as storytellers
is we want each page to be more
interesting than the last page because
the story is building and meaning okay
so as Romeo and Juliet move toward this
climax
the story becomes more interesting we
become more invested the stakes start to
rise because of the struggle that he's
having between what he wants and what he
needs
okay I want you know I I so so you think
about any character they they what they
want is always outside of their
themselves it's always outside of
themselves I want you know I want a pony
and what they need is always within it's
connected to the the why they want the
pony when I get a pony
that'll be popular you know I want I
want to believe in God why do I want to
believe in God because then I'll then
I'll be safe okay so I want to have
faith what do I need I need to trust
okay
that make sense of like you see that's
the dilemma of faith is you know give me
evidence then I'll believe doesn't work
that way that's every story your
protagonist is struggling with a dilemma
and a dilemma is a powerful want and a
false belief those are the two
ingredients okay so I want to believe
but I don't trust and and then your
protagonist is is because what we care
about altum Utley is not whether or not
the protagonist is going to believe or
have faith what we care about is how
your protagonist is going to reframe the
relationship to what faith means what
are things you see most beginning
writers sort of get wrong with writing
an outline plot it's so many writers
think that writing an outline is
figuring out the plot okay and and and
and it's there's something very
satisfying about coming up with a plot
there's something that way oh I've got
it but here's the problem is that again
Einstein says you can't solve a problem
at the same level of consciousness that
created the problem every story begins
with a dramatic problem and what happens
every writers have this experience you
get really excited by your premise and
you you start writing it and you get
halfway through and then you get stuck
and then you're trying to make these
characters interesting but you feel like
they're just
no pieces on a chess board that you're
trying to move around and and and so
it's important to understand that story
structure is not about plotting story
structure really is the DNA of your
protagonists transformation and so what
you really want to do is you want to
start to be curious about your
protagonists dilemma because when you
when you really understand the nature of
their struggle the nature of their
dilemma it is going it becomes the
source of your story and it starts to it
just starts to pay off in silver dollars
it starts to give you all sorts of ideas
images scenarios that are going to
become your plot okay
but if you so so here's the here's what
I would suggest if you want to come up
with a great outline the first thing we
do in the 90 day novel in the 90 day
screenplay is is we spend one week
imagining the world of this story and
doing absolutely no outlining because
what happens is I would say our idea of
our story is never the whole story if
you start to outline your idea of your
story you're gonna get stuck you is it's
gonna become kind of a superficial thing
but if you allow yourself to lose
yourself in your characters relating to
other characters they're going to
surprise you they're gonna be alive and
they're gonna start to do things that
you might not have imagined had you
forced them into a prescribed outline
okay and so that's the first step is
imagine the world of your story allow
your characters to be relating to each
other in ways without imposing any
structure any outline whatsoever now
that you've got all of this raw material
and you start to see how they're related
I'll give you an example you would never
if you're writing It's a Wonderful Life
what does he want he wants to leave
Bedford Falls in order to have a
Wonderful Life the midpoint of that is
where mr. Potter offers Jimmy Stewart a
job that would never if you're outlining
your story that has nothing to do with
what Jimmy Stewart wants okay
he's that's Jimmy mr. Potter's the yet
in the devil okay's the enemy
why would he ever offer him a job that
wouldn't make any sense but if you're
imagining the world of the story and you
come to the midpoint structure question
okay which is how is your protagonist
how does your protagonist experience
temptation it might occur to you that
the devil would tempt him with a big job
offer okay and so that's where I feel
like the way I teach story structure is
different then I've been told it's
different than everybody and it's
because there's no plotting at all
there's these structure questions that
are experiential questions okay
so we're exploring it we're exploring
your the your protagonists experience at
key stages in the the journey okay I
hesitate to say the hero's journey
because then people get this fixed idea
oh you're teaching the hero's journey no
I'm actually not I'm teaching Mateus
that story structure is an immutable
paradigm for a spiritual transformation
and that their key stages that one goes
through including the you know the
reluctance at the end of the first act
the the false hope which we just talked
about I'm talking about now the
mid-point temptation and then suffering
toward the end of the second act and
then finally surrender the end of the
the the the second act these are all
experiences reluctance false hope
temptation suffering surrender they have
nothing to do with plotting and we're
not talking about a reversal you know so
as someone already figuring out the
ending in that in that before they're
beginning of outline you know said think
about it for a week or whatever think
about the the crux of the story what is
it really about are they also figuring
out the ending or is it revealed
sometimes after you do the outline
both it can get revealed after you do
the outline I don't like the word
figuring out because I don't think we
figure anything out but I have an
exercise that give my students to to
experience the ending and and and and
it's a two-part exercise I say imagine
your protagonist transformed at the end
of the story how is your protagonist
relating differently to other care
characters at the end of the story how
are they related differently than they
were at the beginning and what do they
understand at the end of the story that
they didn't understand at the beginning
okay and so and then do that like every
day do that for like 10 minutes every
day and and what you start to plant a
flag for your protagonist at the end of
the story you start to experience your
protagonist at the end of the story
character suggests plot when you start
to experience your character relating
differently to these other characters
plot naturally emerges but you're not
figuring anything out if you try and
figure it out you're gonna get stuck and
then the second thing you want to do is
you want to imagine the if you want to
imagine the climax of your story
remember that we want our protagonists
to be active through the whole story you
want to have an active protagonist and
the challenge for writers is that we
tend to be sort of passive observers
we're always watching what's going on
and so when we sometimes put ourselves
into the protagonists situation
sometimes the protagonist can be the
least interesting character in the story
and so you want to find a way to make
them active the structured questions
they're always going to make your
protagonist active at the climax you
want to think about the difficult choice
your protagonist makes between what he
or she wants and what they need okay
it's a difficult choice so that's an
action I'm making a choice I'm thinking
your protection has to make an act take
an action between what they want what
they need so so think in terms of like
let's say I want justice but I believe
that when I get revenge justice will be
done
so what I want is is actually revenge
okay I want them to pay and what I need
is to have compassion okay so in other
words the end of the story the climax of
the story is we're going to reframe our
relationship to the theme ie justice and
so I'm gonna put my protagonist in a
situation where he can have to make a
difficult choice between what he wants
revenge and what he needs is compassion
that's that in other words if it's not a
difficult choice he would
the choice in act one but it's a it has
to be difficult and it doesn't have to
be sometimes we call it the battle scene
the climax of this story but it doesn't
it doesn't have to be an external battle
it can be an internal battle okay so so
it doesn't have to be it can be an
internal battle that gets dramatized
like if you think about Holly Hunter in
broadcast news the battle scene is her
staring at a plane ticket on a bench at
the airport because William Hurt says
here's the ticket and she's she what she
wants is there to be is she wants there
to be integrity in broadcast journalism
but what she needs is to have integrity
so when William Hurt crosses the line
and fakes a tear in this interview she's
furious and she wants him to take
responsibility for it so that she can go
after this exotic island for a week and
and and and and frolic with him but he's
not going to and and so she is forced to
make a difficult choice within herself
am I gonna get on the plane with William
Hurt or am I gonna get back in the cab
and and so that's that's the battle
scene but it's still active she makes
the choice of getting into the cab so
you want to find a way for your
protagonist to make a difficult choice
between what they want which there's
always outside of themselves ie William
Hurt and what they need which is always
within I'm gonna do the right thing
what's the fastest way to learn
screenwriting the fastest way to learn
screenwriting god
i-i-i i don't know how to answer that
question William Goldman says it's
screenwriting something where sometimes
your second or third one out is as good
as like it's as good as it's gonna be
and but I don't know screenwriting is a
craft
I mean you know they asked Marcus
Margaret Atwood was at a party once and
and some guy she some guy said what do
you she he she said what are you doing
he said I'm a heart surgeon no you said
I'm a brain surgeon and and he said what
do you did she said I'm a writer and he
said oh oh you know what when I retire
I'm gonna be a writer I'm gonna write
and she said oh that's great because
when I retire I'm gonna be a brain
surgeon so it's so it's it's really hard
work and it's a craft and I think that
if if we think sometimes there's another
quote I can't remember who the writer
was but he said writing is some a writer
is someone for whom writing is more
difficult than it is for others well I
love the Margaret out word though
because I remember hearing an interview
where her family said to her okay it's
gonna be difficult for you to be a
writer but we have someone we can invite
over and maybe they can give you advice
right and they were like a journalist at
a paper and they said most like you
likely you'll be writing you know
wedding announcements and all the
queries because at that time women did
and so he I don't think that that was
something that she wanted to do but she
kept with her poetry in and these
different things that's what you know
Francis Coppola he went to film school
and then he said he was hoping that he
was gonna get to do industrial films and
that was gonna be that and and so you
know and he worked for Roger Corman and
he was again I think it's that humility
I think of when we when we sort of
expect that we're supposed to have
everything handed to us nothing happens
but if if if we just put our nose down
and
and just keep working you know great
things can happen and so circling back
to your question about about and now I'm
blanking on the oh the facts weight
capacity writing yeah I fastest way to
learn screenwriting is writing 24 hours
a day okay
except that's not true because if you
don't have I cuz that's what I used to
do when I first started writing I not 24
hours but I wrote all day long and I
didn't have a life and and it wasn't it
wasn't until I kind of got a life and
started to have experiences outside of
comedy clubs and you know going home and
writing in my Garrett that I actually
had something to write about so you know
Paul Newman says he said if you want to
be a writer get a couple of divorces
under your belt you know get some have
something to write about and and have
something that you really care about you
know there are way easier to ways to
make money than being a screenwriter
Woody Allen said I made more money
selling my 5th Avenue duplex then I made
in my entire film career so it's it's
you know if you want to make money buy
rental properties but if you want to be
a screenwriter tell the stories that
matter to you alright well I mean if you
were a comic you depth sure there was a
lot of material even if it's just within
you know you can have stories about
cocktail waitresses and club managers
and I mean so you there was no no no no
hominy comedy isn't about finding
material a comedy is about having a
voice if you have a voice everything can
be funny anything can be funny you know
Mitch Hedberg joke about he said I love
rice I'm gonna butcher but I love
reading I love eating anything
I love eating mm mm of anything but in
other words like you don't have to yeah
if you go out and have a life you're
going to have something
to write about it's it's so so yeah if
if I'm just if I'm just in comedy clubs
all day yeah I guess I could write about
cocktail waitresses but the joke is the
joke is about my point of view so the
way you're gonna develop a point of view
is engaging with the world and starting
to experience what it's like to be a
human being then because the joke isn't
gonna be about the cocktail waitress the
joke is going to be about your
relationship to the cocktail waitress
can writers hold on to their characters
too tightly yeah for sure yeah in fact
yeah I'm always saying we got we got to
hold it loosely if if you're our idea of
our characters is never the whole
character in fact it drives me crazy
when writers say oh my character would
never do that
I think of drama as characters behaving
uncharacteristically okay so a nun robs
a bank you know a bank robber saves a
child on the way out of the bank it's
when you're writing a story or imagining
the world of a story and a character
does something that seems out of
character our job is to trust that and
be curious about how to support it
rather than going my character would
never do that characters can do anything
if you can find a way to support so when
someone says that and you challenge them
do you find that most writers back down
or do they become so stubborn in their
ideas of who that character is that
they're they're not willing to bend well
I don't cheat I don't I don't teach like
that so I don't like I mean if I if I if
I have a care if I have a student who's
challenging me then what is there to
challenge I'm not I'm just asking
questions it's the way I teach it's the
Socratic method I'm not I'm not rakonin
ever my my yeah so I would never have
that with with one of my students I
would just say you know why do you make
that choice that's a question I always
ask my students why do you make that
choice you know why why does the
character do
that and and it's either in other words
you've got we've got to be willing to
explore blind alleys so if if we just
assume that our story's going in in a
particular direction then we might be
denying ourselves you know a lot of
riches by not exploring the the opposite
way I always say to my writers if you
know your characters gonna go left you
have to go right in other words if if in
this scene bill is gonna propose to
Sally and Sally's gonna say yes that's
not an interesting scene Sally will you
marry me yes I will bill that's not a
scene there's no meaning that gets
conveyed convey get a meaning gets
conveyed through conflict or tension and
so we want to explore all the reasons
why bill can't get married and all the
reasons why Sally is afraid to say yes
then now now we're gonna understand what
the scenes about because the scene isn't
about Bill proposing to Sally the scene
is about Bill being afraid to work for
Sally's father you know what I mean will
you work what you know Sally will you
work will you marry me and then we can
spend our lives and I can write tone
poems and she's like no I actually if
I'm gonna marry you you're gonna need to
come work for my dad the hit man you
know now we've got a story okay so we
get you if you know you're gonna go left
go right if you think your characters
gonna do this hold that loosely because
you're going to discover that that that
your idea of your character isn't though
isn't the whole character sign that it's
incorrect it's incomplete and and and
the irony is that when you hold it
loosely your character actually becomes
the most full version of the character
you imagined it's not gonna do exactly
what you wanted it he or she to do but
it's actually going to become you know
the goal of storytelling is for the
whole to be greater than the sum of its
parts not to be the sum of its parts
why do writers get stuck why do writers
get stuck well you want to have a good
outline writers get stuck sometimes
because they you know they come up with
a great idea and they immediately start
writing the idea which is fine but at
some point you're gonna want to stop and
do some kind of an outline and here's
the thing is that this is what writers
will go yeah but I heard that Woody
Allen never outlines and Charlie Kaufman
never outlines and the truth is they do
they probably just don't write their
outline down but they have been writing
stories for such a long time and they've
been and they probably actually do have
lots of notes but they've been doing
that they have developed such an and
manure restructures becomes second
nature for them they've become masters
and so they are naturally seeing they're
naturally connected to this this process
but I would think the main reason
writers get stuck is because they're not
working off some kind of an outline it
could be even the most you know
rudimentary outline but you have to have
something to work from or here's the
irony is that if you don't have an
outline you're actually going to lose
confidence when you get to a point where
you start to feel stuck because you're
always going to get stuck at some point
in the process but if you've got some
kind of basic sense of your the story
structure basic sense of the movement
you can actually get excited about the
point where you get stuck because you
know where the story is going to go and
that's where you can start to move in
all you can you you you can kind of
relax into the panic and let your
characters speak to you and go in
directions that you had never imagined
that are actually going to often support
where the story wants to go okay that's
why I would say if you know you're going
left go right okay so if I know this is
gonna happen let me explore the complete
opposite and relax in the fact that I'm
gonna get to where I'm going it's just
not going I'm not going to arrive there
in the same way I thought I was going to
thinking of like the firm you know Tom
Cruise and then that moment when well I
don't want to give any spoilers away but
I don't think you give me 30 year old
movie yet so I'm just thinking of the
living room scene where he comes back
and and the partners are there and and
maybe I'm pushing oh yeah oh yeah right
and totally different this is where this
is where Robert Towne I love this Robert
Towne adapted the firm okay and he
because I always thought a great novel
except the ending felt like a total
cheat because mitch mcdeere ends up on a
sailboat with ten million dollars
and and and he's like in the Cayman
Islands or something like that and he's
not a lawyer anymore but he wanted to be
a lawyer he loved being a lawyer and so
Robert Towne he read it and he was like
well wait a second why can't he still be
a lawyer at the end of the story but
have a transformation and so he in the
living room scene it's been decades
since I've seen this movie but the
living room scene is where he confronts
the is that is it the mobsters and the I
believe so I think isn't his wife there
too in the isn't maybe I'm picking two
different stories but what he does when
he basically does is he says I'm a
lawyer and I work for you the mob but I
also have all your shit and if anything
happens to me you guys are fucked and so
that's what you know John Grisham didn't
do but that's what makes Robert Towne a
genius is because he understands story
structure he understands transformation
I mean John Grisham is brilliant I love
John Grisham but that the ending of that
felt like
a cop out to me because he just he just
goes off into into like like that ending
is actually a tragedy he's now gonna
spend the rest of his life in hiding in
in the novel in the Cayman Islands in
hiding with ten million dollars that
sounds like a nightmare I don't want it
who wants that life but because he
doesn't get to you know he's gonna be in
hiding but the way Robert Towne did it
was was masterful because it he was true
to the dramatic question that was about
a guy who was an idealistic lawyer who
takes a job for a dirty firm and ends up
in a horror show and he fight and he
manages a way to climb out and outsmart
you know the villains brilliant